hello everyone and happy Women's Day
everyone I don't know if some of you
know this some of you may not know this
but not only is today Women's Day it's
also a day that josé raúl capablanca
died he died in 1942 at the age of 53
and well of course that's very sad but
worry not we will be continuing our
kappa blanka saga and we will be
marveling at his achievements for you
know a very long time getting back to
this game another very nice game from
the Vita World Team Championship
yesterday we saw the first game we we've
shown that it was a nipple versus you
young G here Napo achieved a brilliant
victory and well basically brought
Russia full full to match points but
here we have a match India against China
here this is a I believe board to you
young G vs. Surya Shekhar Ganguly of
India on board one audubon faces ding
Liron which also was a very exciting
game I don't know if you've seen after I
don't want to spoil anything but I will
mention the results at at the end of
this video so let's check it out
you yongi the guy who lost yesterday
against nepo plays d4 for those of you
who might not have seen the video Knight
to f6 we have c4 e6 and now Knight to c3
and not transposing into the Queens
gambit declined but rather Bishop to b4
the nimzo-indian defense but white
continues nice to f3 and we have d5 now
a bit you know they postponed but we are
back in the Queens gambit the client
there are goes in defense now with the
Bishop to b4 move C captures pawn
captures and now Queen to a4 check
trying to pick up the bishop so blacks
response is forced Knight to c6 blocking
check defending the bishop Bishop to g5
now just developing with h6 and Bishop
captures Queen captures and now comes a3
so white decided to give up the bishop
pair early on he will have a very nice
and a very strong light square bishop he
can freely castle and he will try to
make use of his extra Knights extra
night sorry
we have castles by black and now Bishop
to e2 Bishop to d3 seems like a much
more active move but that's basically
inviting Bishop to g4 and here you just
have to go back so why why waste a move
now but on the other hand Bishop on g4
is not all that impressive maybe it's
needed an e6 to guard the d5 pawn so
maybe this Bishop to d3 back to e2 not
not such a terrible idea but okay in the
game Bishop to e2 immediately played
with Bishop to e6 now helping out with
the defense of the d5 pawn also
connecting rooks because once the the
White King castles this will be a threat
we have castles by white and now comes a
six and rook F 2 c1
we have Bishop to d6 now the bishop is
no longer needed here as the King is no
longer on e1 and now black transferred
the the game basically to the Kings side
having a very strong bishop pair black
will now try to create a King side
attack he wants to go 97g if I bring the
Knight to g6 and from there the night
will be very strong yeah would you know
to help out with the attack Queen to be
won and already this is move 13 but
there are almost 102 games in the
database with this exact same position
so this is still considered to be the
basically standard theory of this
opening Knight to e7 Ganguly continues
with his plan will Knight to a4 now
hoping to get this night all the way to
c5 to force force a trade here black of
course does not allow this we have b6
and now before a very nice idea of how
to grab more space on the Queen side
because you cannot capture here your c7
pawn will be hanging so here after b4
there have been other moves that have
been played here in the database like
rook F the b8 was a movie in immediately
g5 has been played here but the move in
the game is a new move for this position
Ganguly please a5 and now we have a
completely new game that was never
played before
we have b5 now and g5 and I'll just
pause the video here as I do have one
photo of this moment and I think it was
taken around this moment I don't know if
it's exactly in this moment also by
David Lara it's the only one I have I
don't have the the decibel bonding we
were in versus audubon but in the back
you can see you young he and his
opponent is missing but I think
position is about right and it's the
only one I have so you know do enjoy it
get more into the mood for the game
there you have it nothing out of the
ordinary there so let's get back to this
game g5 played Knight to g6 as planned
will be coming and now nice to be to the
white knight is no longer needed on the
edge of the board so white wants to
bring it back into the game via Knight
me to to d3 Knight to g6 by black and
now Knight to d3 and here rook 88 we
have Knight F 2 e1 and now just H 5 and
this H 5 move is very interesting it's a
it's an the reason I really like it is
because it's a it's really a human move
very nicely done a very brave pawn
sacrifice where you basically say to
white either I'm just gonna start you
know a massive attack here or you can
capture my pawn I'm gonna go King g7 and
have the semi open H file for my rooks
and here white grabs the pawn Bishop
captures on h5 is played which is not a
mistake or anything you know it's it's a
nice pawn if you can defend why not King
to g7 as planned now the rook is coming
all the way to the H file and here white
has an option in the game h3 was played
but you could also play captures on g6
and after Queen captures 95 which would
allow black a very strong attack but it
seems white would be okay let's say
queen h7 and now I'll just look the c6 a
very a very nice rook lifts and after f6
attacking the knight just a night here
and now if Bishop captures Queen
captures you can even capture on h2 but
it's not gonna be a problem King with
one and now there's really no way to
successfully continue this king hunt so
white will be perfectly fine here but
it's not something you want to allow I
mean I allow such a thing so first h3
was played and now comes a rock to h8
taking control of the h-file Bishop to
g4 we have Bishop captures and here
Queen captures was a must play move
Queen captures was the best idea here
but most likely youngji decided not to
do it as it allows this rook to info
you know with an attack on the Queen so
he decided to go H chapter Sun g4 but H
capture Sun g4 is a huge blunder
which you know now that I've told you
it's a huge blunder now of course you
understand what's going on but just in
case you don't feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out why
this move was a huge blunder and how
black can take advantage of this
position I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent sacrificer of rooks on
e3 and for those who just want to enjoy
show the movies rook captures on e3 and
an excellent move you can see that if
the rook is captured the Queen controls
the entire F file the rook is
controlling the entire H file so there's
bound to be something here but it's
actually a force mace if you capture you
can just sacrifice the rook rook h1
check the Queen control via file you
have the capture and now Queen if one
will be checkmate as the bishop controls
the h2 square so quite a lovely idea
this rook to H a rook to e3 move you
cannot capture it first rook to c6 now
any bunch of h2 ideas which check will
also come with an attack on the black
Queen but it is it is what you want to
do will bushel H to check kink the f1
now and here
Ganguly just tries bishop - geez g3 I
just you know the good old you know you
take my queen I'm gonna checkmate you
with rook to h1 but of course young G
does not fall for this he just repeats
keep the g1 and here we have one of the
first repetition of moves as Ganguly was
well most likely trying to reach time
control so he would have more time to
enjoy his better position Bishop to H
the check was played King to f1 and now
Bishop to g3 again going for this idea
King to g1 and now if you repeat it you
would have a three-fold repetition but
the best idea was not now and you don't
want to allow a three-fold repetition
but in one of the previous moves after
Bishop days - King f1 Bishop back to d6
but now that the king is on f1
it's a different story if the King
repeats now you go rook to e6 you get
the rook out of harm's way and now
whitey just has a really the
called game whatever he plays like the
queen of three maybe we want to try to
trade Queens Knight f4 and now if
captures captures it's just a lost
position for black Queen h4 is coming to
h1 not a lot of ways you can stop this
so it's really just it would be just
winning for black but Ganguly had a
different plan he played Queen captures
on d4 well probably he didn't find
anything better but almost likely if he
repeated it would also be a three-fold
repetition so you can go for that but
this allows white to trade off a few
pieces and well survive for the moment
Knight to see two attacks the Queen and
the rook we have Bishop to h2 check
first and now you can go King to f1 here
a Ganguly is just testing you Angie if
he would go King f1 then Queen captures
comes with check now you have to capture
on you're just down a piece so now he
has to go King to eight one and two now
Queen to Bishop to f4
I discovered check from the rook King to
G 1 and now once again a repetition of
Moose Kings the h1 Bishop f4 check King
G one and only now Queen captures on d3
so it's on already moved 33 we are
reaching time control that is move 40
but now white can grab the rook Knight
captures we have Bishop to h2 check once
again King to h1 and now Bishop to e5
check King to g1 now Bishop to h2 check
once again King to h1 and now finally
with Queen captures on b5 so what's
what's the result here you can see that
white has two rooks a knight and the
Queen and black has a queen a knight a
bishop and the rook so white is actually
up material but his position isn't all
that impressive here white played rook a
to c1 better was Knight to f5 check
immediately you don't want to allow
black to prevent to this check which
white did white played first rook e8 2
c1 double rooks here the idea is at some
point to play g3 and maybe be able to
capture on c7 but it's not not really
possible as whenever this bishop moves
it will be with Czech
Bush of the g3 check King to g1 and now
Bishop to h2 check once again King each
one and now nice the e7 comes with an
attack on the rook but
also prevents this Knight to f5 check
which is even more important for but for
black young he played the g3 he wants to
play king 2g do and now just Knight
captures on c6 why decided to give back
at the exchange Knight to f5 check for
this very nice check King to f8 and now
comes King to g2 we have Bishop captures
and g3 that Bishop isn't really going
anywhere so you might as well traded
Knight captures on g3 and now rook to h6
so now when everything is said and done
you can see that white survived the
attack but he's down three pawns and
it's not gonna be an easy game from here
on we have Knight to f5 attacks the rook
rook to e6 and now Queen to f3 white is
still trying to fight this game with
Queen to be two attacks the rook rook
has to move we have looked to h1 with
ideas of infiltrating to the other back
rank and then now Knight to e7 black now
wants to trade down and enjoy his Queen
and rook endgame with three three extra
pawns Queen g3 we have Knight captures
pawn captures and now rook to e2 so here
black just says you are not leaving with
the Queen the Queen must stay here to
keep an eye on the f2 pawn and I don't
really care what you do with your h1
rook so Queen to f3 here attacking the
pawn here but it's not really I mean you
constantly have to keep an eye on this
point we have Queen to e5 now just
improving the position centralize your
Queen there you know I always everyone
always emphasizes this but it's really
really important to centralize your
queen sometimes you can even sacrifice a
pawn just to centralize your Queen it
will be well worth it we have f6 now you
yongi threatens rook to H a check me to
have to avoid this we have King t8 and
now look to h8 check King d7 and not
rope to f8 so this rook infiltrated very
nicely but it will not be of any help
Queen t6 is defending the pawn here and
now Queen to h5 preparing to capture the
pawn here but now comes the Queen e4
check and now white really doesn't have
all that many options if you go
something like King g3 then just queen
for checking each tree Queen
captures and you have no good defense
against this whatever you play either
Queen captures on f7 or rook after Sun
f7 doesn't really do anything King c6
and now there are no more no more checks
here that you can use ei it is covered
by the rook so next year just getting
checkmated queen h2 can rubgy - so after
this Queen to b4 move why decided to
block with the Queen but now it's just
an end game where you're up three pawns
Queen captures with her King captures on
f3 and not rook captures an e2 rook
captures on f7 with check and now kink
the e6 captures captures and now rook
the c6 check black a white will win the
besets pawn but still King get five will
captures and now it's three points
against one okay it's two extra pawns
but quite enough for a grandmaster to
end this game
Rukia check was played with King t2 and
the now comes a four we have looked to
d6 going after the pawn just King G for
defending the pawn now rook to e6 check
King d4 rook to g6 going after the pawn
but it doesn't matter for black black
has plenty of material rokay to check
king of three and now just a three so
like that doesn't mind giving up this
pawn is it's not an important part of
the game anymore and after rook to c2 it
was under Smoove it was in this position
of mostly the 666 ad that Chinese
Grandmaster you young he resigned the
game so an excellent victory for surah
shaker Ganguly white resigned as
whatever he plays is just a to a-1
I mean you have to block it somehow now
King c3 after the King comes to be to
the pawn will promote you can't really
do anything even the D pawn is very
dangerous not really much you can do
here
King g3 you can just move the rook or
King but there are no useful news just
came here and you will not promote the
pawn and win the game yeah after rook
the c2 a wonderful victory for for the
Chinese grandmas
sorry for the Indian Grandmaster and
like I mentioned China had a a very
close match against the United States
that China was then China faced Russia
also lost due to that victory over
we'll head over you young e and now you
young he once again loses again through
a shaker ganguly but like I said I will
now spoil the results a bit I don't know
if any of you are following the
championship but Busey on g1 his game on
board for for China
so China did not lose this match against
India the match was a draw but
interestingly Bhaskar inaudible he drew
his game against England and now in the
live Redding's he has crossed the 2700
trading threshold so he has now now
joined the 2,700 Club so big you know
big success for for Audubon and we're
gonna cover one more game today from
from the world feed abroad team
championship and we're gonna talk a bit
more about the team results then and
Elias had a really really awesome
victory in his game so we're definitely
gonna show that but yeah it's it all
went downhill here after this instead of
Queen captures on g4 h captures on g4
was played which allowed this very nice
rook sacrifice and that was just it yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Russell Lloyd
they've bore Andrew Slater and informed
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon most
likely with one more game from defeated
World Team Championship but also still
figuring out in which direction to
continue the capablanca saga and I know
a lot of you are wondering where is the
subscribers video it's almost done so
expect it like next week most probably I
know I said I will publish it most
likely in January but you know there
better not to rush anything so it you
know it's as good as it can be in the
end
I think you all and I will see you soon